THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
WE ENJOYED WATCHING THE RALLY
LAST NIGHT.
AND THE KEY TO WINNING FLORIDA
FOR TRUMP IS GETTING OUT MORE OF
THE LATINO VOTE.
WE KNOW THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT, TRUMP HAS
A REAL FIGHTER ON HIS SIDE.
>> WE HAVE ONE OF THE GREATEST
FIGHTERS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD,
JORGE MASVIDAL.
HE’S A CHAMP.
HE’S GOT THAT HARD.
HE’S GOT THAT HARD, THANK YOU,
MAN.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE LIKE HIM, I
CAN TELL YOU.
>> Laura: JOINED ME NOW IS UFC
FIGHTER JORGE MASVIDAL.
JORGE, WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Laura: WE’VE BEEN SEEING A
LOT THAT TRUMP IS DOING BETTER
AMONG HISPANICS, SO ARE YOU
SEEING THAT ON THE GROUND?
IS IT ACTUALLY TRUE?
>> IT’S A RED WAVE HERE.
IT’S GETTING HOTTER AND HOTTER.
THE RED WAVE IS A REAL THING.
PEOPLE WAITED FOR HOURS
YESTERDAY FOR A RALLY AND ABOUT
25,000 INDIVIDUALS WERE THERE.
SPIELER ALL IN ALL, JORGE, IS
ICAP SAYING TODAY IF I HAD TO
PICK ONE RALLY TO GO TO, THE ONE
IN MIAMI WOULD BE THE MOST FUN,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY’S DANCING AND
THERE’S MUSIC AND EVERYONE
AROUND THE COUNTRY IS LIKE
WEIGHT -- THEY WANT ME TO BE
MISERABLE, BUT PEOPLE ACTUALLY
SEEM TO BE HAVING FUN IN THE FUN
FACTOR PEOPLE HAVE TO NOT IGNORE
I THINK.
>> NO, WE HAVE A GREAT TIME.
AS YOU SAID, THE LIVE MUSIC WAS
PLAYING, WATER BOTTLES WERE
BEING HANDED OUT.
WAITING FOR A PRESIDENT TO COME
AND JUST GIVE SOME WORDS OF
WISDOM AND ENCOURAGEMENT. HEADLI
"WHY ARE SO MANY EX-ATHLETES
RISKING THEIR LEGACIES BY
ENDORSING DONALD TRUMP THIS LATE
IN THE ELECTION"?
I KNOW YOU ARE STILL FIGHTING
BUT DO YOU THINK YOU ARE RISKING
YOUR LEGACY BY ENDORSING
DONALD TRUMP?
>> DEFINITELY.
WE SEE EVERYWHERE, THEY TRY TO
CANCEL -- THEY JUST GIVE CHARITY
EVENTS.
WHEN THE HURRICANES CAN TO
PUERTO RICO, THEY SENT TONS OF
PEOPLE THERE IN PLACES LIKE
VENEZUELA AND WE HAD TO CANCEL
CULTURE BECAUSE I HAD A BUSINESS
MEETING.
I’M NOT GOING TO BE INTIMIDATED
BY NO MOB.
I’M NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON YOU
CAN -- YOU TALK IT OUT.
SO I DON’T CARE, I’M SPEAKING
FROM MY HEART, I’M SPEAKING FOR
THOSE THAT CAN’T SPEAK LIKE MY
FATHER, LIKE MY AUNT THAT
ESCAPED COMMUNIST CUBA.
I HAVE TO BE A MOUTHPIECE.
I’M DEFINITELY NOT GETTING MORE
FOLLOWERS OR MORE FRIENDS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT FOR ENDORSING
PRESIDENT.
QUITE THE OPPOSITE, BUT I DON’T
CARE.
YOU KNOW, I HONESTLY DON’T CARE.
>> Laura: JORGE, I DON’T
KNOW -- WHERE ARE YOU, BY THE
WAY?
WHERE IS THAT?
>> I CAME TO HAVE A MILK SHAKE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
OKAY, AGAIN, EVERYBODY HAS FUN
DOWN IN FLORIDA.
OR WHEREVER YOU ARE.
ARE YOU IN FLORIDA?
>> I’M IN.